let's hear her interview yeah you just
played the draw against hikaru nakamura
was it i was wondering was it was it
your shortest ever game in classical
chess
could it be i'm not sure so
uh considering the number of moves
surely not no not the fastest
uh you know the quantity of moves but uh
yeah maybe it didn't took too long but i
mean in general i like had a mindset
okay if he plays his normal stuff like
berlin
maybe it's not the right moment you know
to invest too much energy to refute it
and just i mean to
uh to take this draw and uh prepare to
for the rest games but uh i mean of
course i was preparing for some some
other minds like i know cecilia and some
puke and so on but
yeah he chose the stability so
here we go yeah how much time actually
you spent for your preparation i was
wondering uh quite some time
so i think uh
i mean okay clearly that in case a
burden you play i mean if in case of
berlin you just take a draw you're white
there are many different ways
uh but there are like many openings
which
probably you want to play as for for
arenas black but
i mean when you start repeating you
you know you can never stop
where are you surprised with his
decision to to play like this today no i
thought it's like the most uh
the most natural because he sticks to
his best openings and that's what he
does but uh yeah of course even if the
you know the probability was uh
i would say the highest amount
among all openings still it wasn't the
reason like not to take care about some
you know any others yeah what are you
going to do now that you have almost
like two three days no it's not like two
three days of course i
try to take you know as much time for
for having rest as possible
and uh i mean once again like there are
different scenarios and
last two games they could be also very
tense so it's
nothing like over